bevor wir über frontverläufe und neue
wichtige strategische schüssel fragen
sprechen möchte ich ihnen einmal mein
foto der nacht zeigen ein bild was bei
kollege julian röpke von einem kontakt
aus der ost ukraine zugeschickt bekommen
hat das ist ein waisenhaus in der
ukraine ein keller und schauen sie mal
an wie dort die pädagogen die erzieher
auf die kleinen aufpassen müssen 45
babys im bett nebeneinander so geht man
dort ja man kann es ja gar nicht sagen
in schutz aber so sucht man schon
probiert putins bomben aus dem weg zu
gehen lassen sie uns dieses bild gleicht
nicht vergessen wenn wir über
schlüsselfragen sprechen denn es geht am
ende um genau diese menschen und darum
diese menschen zu schützen und etwas zu
tun dass sie irgendwie diesen krieg
vielleicht überleben können als
allererstes warum sind diese menschen im
keller na klar weil über ihn darf ein
die bomben und da ist terror und zwar
mittlerweile terror im dunkeln das haben
wir gesehen aber terror auch im hellen
und zwar auf dem boden überall schauen
sie hier ein wohnblock in carson hier
unten da brennt es schon und jetzt
achten sie gleich einmal hier oben ein
ganz normaler wohnblock familienleben wo
menschen leben und dann auf einmal
schlägt dort das nächste geschoss ein
völlig willkürlich trifft ist die leute
gehören die anwohner die das filmen die
angst um ihr leben haben schlägt die
nächste bombe die nächste gerade
vielleicht bei mir ein dass der bittere
der tragische der schreckliche alltag
auch hier noch mal ein video aus cars
sollen wir sehen gleich einen russischen
schützenpanzer ich mag ihn einmal für
sie der kommt hier die straße
hinuntergefahren und geht dann nach hier
oben in stellung und wird gleich quer
durch diesen ort schießen vollkommen
klar wer da in den weg kommt wer da in
der nähe ist der wirt getroffen von dem
geschoss von schrott nähen von glas von
splittern von schutt und hat am ende
keine chance zu überleben
was sich der alltag so sieht er aus hört
er sich an und so brutal ist der
menschen mittlerweile für die menschen
in der ukraine
teilweise hat es vorhin gesagt es gibt
aber noch ein anderes bild aus der
ukraine das eine das zeigt diese
unglaubliche brutalität und das andere
das zeigt vielleicht ein stück weit das
stümperhafte vorgehen der russischen
armee ich habe in den letzten 24 stunden
mit 3 nato generäle sprechen können und
sie gefragt was was ist das für sie
erstaunlichste was wo schauen sie am
meisten hin und da gab es ein wort was
wir immer wieder gehört haben die
logistikkette die logistikkette die
offenbar so gar nicht gut funktioniert
das hier das ist eine aufnahme von einer
landstraße aus der ukraine und ich lass
dir jetzt einfach hinter mir laufen in
das video das läuft insgesamt zwei
minuten lang und sie werden am rand
immer wieder russische militärfahrzeuge
sehen viele hunderttausend euro wert was
da am straßenrand steht vollkommen
intakt nicht getroffen nicht zerstört
und dennoch verlassen einfach am
straßenrand warum weil eben die logistik
der russen an vielen fronten so nicht zu
funktionieren scheint dazu gibt es eine
abkürzung militärs die lieben leider
abkürzungen und zwar die abkürzung btg
das ist die taktische bataillons gruppe
und das sozusagen ist der verband in dem
die russen sich normalerweise bewegen
vielleicht kann man das in unserer
umgangssprache sowas wie die eierlegende
wollmilchsau nennen denn die russen sind
normalerweise unterwegs mit fuß soldaten
mit panzern mit logistik mit pionieren
alle zusammen unterwegs und so kann man
eben wenn man sich im feindesland bewegt
dann am besten hat alle fähigkeiten
abrufen hat immer alles dabei wenn die
brücke kaputt ist würde ich die pioniere
und repariere die brücke wenn ich feuer
unterstützung brauche dann fahre ich die
artillerie auf und so ist man mit allen
gemeinsam unterwegs das alles erfordert
aber eine hohe kommunikationsfähigkeit
eine starke führung dass ich all diese
truppenverbände gemeinsam und auf einmal
steuer und lenkte wenn mir das nicht
gelingt und es gelingt den russen an
vielen fronten überhaupt nicht da
passiert folgendes die panzer fand vor
die soldaten in den fahrzeugen fahren
vor und hinter mir die versorgung die
logistik der sprit das benzin das bleibt
ungeschützt zurück und kann dann
zerstört werden und die folge ist dass
dann vorne die panzer irgendwann ohne
sprit ohne benzin dastehen und na klar
einfach liegen bleiben am straßenrand
wir sehen ganz
mittlerweile truppenverbände die intakt
am straßenrand stehen geparkt und wo
stehen und von den russen russen nicht
mehr bewegt werden können hier geht
etwas komplett schief bei den russen
etwas was das habe mir die nato generäle
gesagt überrascht dass hat man anders
erwartet vielleicht liegt es daran dass
die soldaten am ende schlecht
ausgebildet sind viel jünger sind als
dass die russen selbst immer gesagt
haben dass erfahrene soldaten kampf
abrupt erfahren wir sehen ja auch bädern
wie jungen diese russischen soldaten
sind 17 18 19 19 jahre sind teilweise
selbst noch aus wie kinder und offenbar
funktioniert die kommunikation eben auch
nicht also dass die diese verbände an
steuern und lenken am ende sagen jetzt
logistik dahin jetzt kerosin benzin
dahin dass alles funktioniert nicht und
die folge ist die russen bleiben liegen
und ein video das ist wirklich der
wahnsinn hier aufgenommen was passiert
wenn ich irgendwann meinen panzer nicht
mehr steuern kann wenn ich mein fahrzeug
nicht mehr habe na klar ich muss laufen
und zwar zurück nach russland hier
aufgenommen aus dem norden der ukraine
russische soldaten die ihre fahrzeuge
nicht mehr bewegen konnten und sich zu
fuß zurück auf den weg nach russland
machen leider viel zu wenig davon muss
man sagen man würde sich wünschen es
werden tausende die so zurück laufen
würden die die waffen wegwerfen ihrer
fahrzeuge stehen lassen und zurückgehen
aber doch immerhin schon noch einmal
drauf hier am anfang immerhin diese
soldaten also abgeschnitten von ihrer
eigenen logistik und damit bringt dir
der größte und stärkste panzer gar
nichts wenn du am ende kein sprit mehr
hast um ihn anzutreiben dass also der
zustand der russischen armee
zusammengefasst extrem brutal die
aufnahmen haben wir gesehen aber
offenbar auch an vielen fronten
überfordert und ein stück weit
stümperhaft